I have another one of these fill in the
blank triangle proof exercises but this
time instead of doing it on my own
little digital notebook I'm going to do
it right on the exercise because they're
actually our tools so that you can mark
up the diagrams so first they tell us
that segment BC is parallel to DF bc is
parallel to DF figure not drawn to scale
fair enough and we're going to prove its
involved as important if we're gonna do
a proof to know what we're going to
prove we're going to prove the triangle
EBD so that's this triangle down here is
congruent to triangle e bc so this one
right over here that this triangle is
congruent to that triangle that's what
we're going to try to prove so let's see
what Givens they gave us they say that
and you see when you scroll over they
show you which two angles are talking
about that angle EBD or bde is congruent
to angle ACB so let me mark those so I
just click once to show that those two
are congruent then they say that these
two segments de and AC or congruent so
let me mark those you just click on them
click on them once it does one slash
mark if you click on it more than once
it'll do more than one slash mark then
we also know that these two are
congruent b.ed and BAC so let me put two
arks here to show that they are not
necessarily congruent to these other two
so I did those now we have this one b.ed
which we've already marked that's b.ed
right over there is congruent to c e f
so that's just telling us that CEF this
angle is the same as this one so I can
put the double hash marks there and then
they tell us that be e is congruent to
EF so ve is congruent to EF and then
finally they tell us that angle dbe is
congruent to c f e so dbe up at three
dbe it's going to c c f e so now let's
try to prove Purdue our proof and
they've already kind of done a scaffold
of our proof and we need to essentially
fill in the blanks so this first thing
they're comparing two triangles and
they're say there's two triangles are
congruent because of angle side angle so
what what can wear it can we even sit
make that statement well we have this
triangle right over here we
say it's congruent to this triangle up
here by angle side angle angle side
angle or or we could say that this
triangle is congruent to this triangle
because you have this angle side angle
this angle side angle so it's not clear
based on just this blank which one they
want us to describe but let's let's go
further down in the proof and maybe
it'll become more obvious well then they
have this blank right over here blank
equals blank because corresponding parts
of congruent triangles are congruent
once again there probably is probably
based on which two triangles we picked
to be congruent this is going to be one
of them but we don't know whether it's
going to be that one or that one
depending on how this proof is going
down then they say that triangle ABC is
congruent to EBD so then they say that
this triangle is congruent to this
triangle right over here well if down
here they're making that statement then
up here they must want us to say that
this triangle is congruent to this
triangle right over here so we can say
that EBD or maybe i'll say d let's I'll
do EBD EBD is congruent juices EBD the
double arc double side triple side is
going to be congruent to double arc
double slashes triple side so EFC
because of a SI e FC there you go and it
filled it in which is a good indication
that we did it right all right and then
let's see what else can we say so now
remember we're trying to prove that this
triangle right over here is congruent to
this triangle so based on this we just
said that this triangle on the left is
congruent to this triangle on the right
given that they're congruent what is
useful information so that we can get
information about this middle triangle
well this middle triangle shares a side
show your side ec with this triangle
over here so we should say that side ec
is congruent to something over here
which will help us set up that this
middle triangle is congruent so based on
the fact that eb d and e FC are
congruent eces corresponding side would
be what well it's between it's the side
that's opposite the triple angle so it's
going to its course it's going
to correspond to side de so we could say
that de is congruent to EC de is
congruent to EC because their
corresponding sides they're both the
sides opposite this triple angle de is
course is equal or segments de is
congruent to segment ec there you go and
that worked out all right and then they
say triangle ABC and EBD so that's this
one and this one are congruent because
and we already went over this there's
multiple ways that you can say there can
well actually no there's there's only
one they have this angle side angle
angle side angle that's why they are two
they're congruent so we have
angle-side-angle congruence and then we
can say that bc is congruent to BD well
those are corresponding sides of
congruent triangles those are both the
sides opposite the double arc opposite
the double arc and then up here opposite
the double arc so that's because
couldn't there can they are
corresponding parts of congruent
triangles and then finally so let me let
me mark let me mark those off so this is
that is congruent to that corresponding
parts of congruent triangles and then
finally we can prove the statement and
actually you could probably guess what
this last one was because that this was
the end of the proof that EVD is
congruent is congruent to ebc EBD EBD is
congruent to ebc and that's once again
because you have side side side we've
shown that these three sides are
congruent to these three sides it's
congruent to ebc and you want to make
sure you get the order right so E is
that is the side is the is the angle
opposite the three sides on this
triangle and it's also the side opposite
the three sides on that one and then
corresponding to be B is opposite the
single side and over here B is opposite
the single site so it's going to be bc
its congruent to e bc because of side
side side and let's check our answer
drumroll and it's right very good